what in the world is that you're talking
about all Muslims have condemned no
actually we know them
wait a minute Billa Bill O'Reilly you
should be happy that he's unindicted you
are running the water he's going to kill
me tonight it is an indicted being
unindicted is something good not bad why
is he an indicted is a good thing
assalamualaikum greetings of peace
welcome to the D show you want to
continue on talking about Muhammad Ali
the people's champ
America's champion last week we talked
about him and the week before why not we
finish off the month continuing talking
about the American Muslim hero with the
person who knew him personally president
sound vision who is also on the spin
factor with Bill O'Reilly let me tell
you I'm willing to bring you there is
going to be a conference of 10,000
people from 80 countries and I don't
think that's good I'll give you the
laughs wryly many people bill told me
why are you going to on his show because
many people consider you are a radical
person you need to build bridges of
understanding among people and we need
to have America moving forward this is
the time for unity this is not the time
for division Bill O'Reilly try to trip
him up he got tripped up someone who's
in a field of sharing this Deen clearing
up the many misconceptions and you know
what you guess how much you spent on
bashing Islam over I mentioned 159
million this brother is telling us that
over 200 million dollars is spent on
promoting hate of Islam and Muslims
which you can do about it what you can
go ahead how you can make a difference
about it here to teach other
this is the assalamualaikum greetings a
piece how are you sharing walaikum
A'Salam what a liar got a Ramadan
melodic Ramadan Mubarak thank you for
being wolf I was here on the Deen show
well thank you for inviting me it's a
great day and a great deal hamdulillah
I'm gonna show a clip and I want to get
your your feedback on that and from
there we want to talk about double
standards and I want to we're gonna let
our audience see this and we'll come
back and get your comments on it but at
Sacramento's Verity Baptist Church
Pastor Roger Jimenez told his
churchgoers what have you asked me hey
are you sad that 50 pedophiles were
killed today um no I think that's great
I I think that helps society you know I
think Orlando Florida is a little safer
tonight
now that 50 you know the tragedy is that
more of them than die I mean the tragedy
is I'm kind of upset that he finish the
job everybody Pastor Steven Anderson
here from faithful Word Baptist Church
in Tempe Arizona and I just wanted to
record a quick video about the news this
morning about the shooting in Orlando I
guess a Muslim terrorist went into a gay
bar and shot him up and there's 50
sodomites homosexuals that have been
killed and another 50 some-odd injured
and then the the Muslim guy himself was
was shot by the police it sounds like
and here's the good news and the bad
news about this you know the good news
is that there's 50 less pedophiles in
this world because you know these
homosexuals are a bunch of disgusting
perverts and pedophiles that's who was a
victim here are a bunch of just
disgusting homosexuals at a gay bar okay
and then I'm sure it's also going to be
used to push an agenda against so-called
hate speech so Bible believing Christian
preachers who preach what the Bible
actually says about homosexuality that
it's vile
it's disgusting that there reprobates
you know we're gonna be blamed like oh
it's it's it's all extremism it's not
just the Muslims it's the Christians did
you have any regrets about your
statements during your sermon on Sunday
I don't have any regrets about what I
said and I don't take anything back I
would never take things into my own
hands have become a vigilante but I will
say this you know the Bible says that
homosexuals should be put to death in
Leviticus 20:13
now shake obviously this was a horrific
event Islam has nothing to do with such
evil acts when you look into this
person's life you obviously see and
usually when someone does a horrific act
like for instance you had the the Briton
first when I was screaming Britain first
killed that MP Joe Cox and they probably
gonna look in his life see if he's
mentally deranged or whatnot but when it
comes to to Muslims and she's like they
want to connect the dot all the way
always to Islam so when you hear you
know anything if Muslim would have said
something like this mainstream media
coverage 24/7 what are your thoughts are
that when you see this double it is
blatant obvious double standard that's
going on oh it's very clear I mean last
year more than 200 mass shootings took
place in America only two places a
Muslim were accused of doing that but
none of the other people were called
terrorists none of the other people as a
focus actually a professor of
communication has done research that 80%
of the focus of domestic terrorism is on
Muslims while Muslims are not more than
5 percent responsible for domestic
terrorism so that that is very clear but
I would say two elements play a role in
their Islamophobes Islamophobes are a
two hundred million dollar machine here
I just found out yes there are there are
just 34 organizations close knit they
got PhDs and professors and public and
and whatnot and they got huge funding so
like Dean didn't show probably struggles
that couple of people are trying to keep
up the flag up so the Sun vision which
is has been there
twenty-eight years but these people have
$200,000,000 behind them what do they do
they do one thing as soon as some crazy
dude that's something anywhere in the
world say haha you see this is what
Islam is all about Islam is the problem
Quran is the problem it's not one crazy
person so this is a Slama folk using
media very skillfully against Islam and
Muslim my question to you is brother
Dean what are you going to do about it
you're a media person we're trying to
combat it I think the solution is
education I think we need to make the
human connection you know and I think
people who are sincere and they look
into really what Islam is about as many
did after these tragic events such as
9/11 Amazon had the highest sale of
Quran it was because people were curious
and people wanted to know and then they
ended up accepting Islam can you imagine
that yes he saw through the rhetoric yes
some of them but but you know after 9/11
there was fifty nine percent approval
rating of Islam and Muslim in this
country now seventeen percent and at
that survey is before the Orlando
tragedy so Muslims need to be more
thoughtful instead of just spending
money on disaster relief or helping our
brothers and sister which is very
genuine and instead of just building a
mosque in ninety percent of money going
to mosque and minaret a thousand dollars
I would like to have couple of minaret
for brother Dean because you see we need
to stand up Islamophobia is not a
product because people have not read the
Quran people did not read the Quran
fifty years ago but there was no
Islamophobia Islamophobia is product of
our weakness and Islamophobes are
hitting and being successful in
manipulating media because we are not in
the media we are not taking a stand we
do not have coalition in this society so
we are weak in this society so Muslim
need to reset the budget divert some of
their funding towards strengthening
themselves in the society in the
community and also investing
the media so being more proactive in the
media educating people through the media
using this great resource like they're
using against right I can't solve it
five hundred two hundred million rather
that's all which we know because thanks
to IRS returned yeah there is much much
more money two hundred million dollar
does not include Fox television which
itself is a billion-dollar operation so
we are facing a major thing but this
small group of Islamophobes our
neighbors are not as now folks of
neighbors are just confuse yeah they
didn't hear anything else because they
were asked why you're against Islam and
Muslims and guess what
majority of them said because of the
video it's on the TV so we need to be on
the TV we need to isolate Islamophobes
from the mainstream media bring our
stories up so media people need to be
handled as though they're human being
instead of just a big machine each
Muslim individual if you see something
say something see something what you see
on TV yeah pick up the phone and call
them hey what I see is wrong how come
you're not telling this how come you're
not saying that about you know Facebook
is knocked off good post about what
terrorism was taking place in Orlando
and what other factors are responsible
where's the Muslim voices speaker is
stand up that's what also la salle
Allah's Salam because good words speak
up Stan and we're gonna take a break how
mad what do you think got some good good
points there Howard yeah yeah but
underline harm it says some hum it is
very shrewd rather we're gonna take a
big operative I'm telling you don't let
him go millions are spent to get people
away from Islam we're asking you to
contribute very little to help share and
bring people to this beautiful way of
life Islam now what are you gonna do
with that how much are you going to put
in how much are you going to contribute
to help us grow this channel to continue
the work it's something that's incumbent
on all of us we've taken up the call
we're doing our small part may Allah so
Allah accept it from us and from you as
you contribute there's a link below
we'll see you next time keep us in your
do I subscribe if you haven't already to
get the newest show delivered to you
every Friday we release it helps support
the Dawa helps support our spreading the
message of peace and purpose to the
world until next time we'll see you the
Salaam o alaikum peace be with you
back here on the D show check how are
you doing how you've been thank you for
finding the time to be with us you
actually what you were somebody who we
just had probably the best PR that we've
had in I mean decades I would say you
know with I would say decades but in a
long time and we had this individual who
was an American and many people had sad
to say they don't know that he was
Muslim even though his name spells it
out ma how American hero Muhammad
Muhammad Ali you actually you spent time
with him you knew him personally exact
oh yes well brother Muhammad Ali you
know it's like all Muslims you know we
struggle with our faith with our
practices but he when it comes to faith
he was from when it comes to telling
people what Islam he was from and even
in his death he did a big favor to
Muslim for one week America was talking
about somebody named Muhammad Ali and he
fought for his name in we did many
things you never used to distribute you
know meat after Eid al-adha problem was
how to distribute to the poor so I
worked with Muhammad Ali and he built a
mosque in Chicago outside that mass will
distribute that but you will be happy to
know I invited him to help the Bosnian
cause in those days Muslims were not
much known our leadership was not known
so we took him and he readily happily
came to New York we went to ambassador
after ambassador to stop the crisis in
genocide in Bosnia oh yeah he he had had
the cost then there was a rally for
philosophy in Chicago and I say who
cares for Muslim so I said mama deli if
you come rally will be on TV and guess
what Muhammad Ali came and join and
that's where a CBS reporter asking me
why is he here
I say because he supports philosophy he
said know why I support velocity I say
well Muhammad Ali is a Muslim oh I
didn't know Muhammad Ali he's
emotionally don't know that Muhammad
name and people don't know this should
be an example for kids changing their
name when you see this person now who is
example of someone who in our day and
age was proud to be one who submits to
the will of the critter like Jesus know
people used to call him clay and he said
no call me Muhammad Ali Mohammed yeah
he's a poem about days he fought on this
name he forced people to accept his name
and children right now about 30% of them
don't use their Muslim name so this is
because of the pressure but Muhammad Ali
is an example
Muhammad Ali was not popular when he was
doing his popular and now he was not
popular at the people used to split on
him
people will refuse to use his name and
he will just say I am what I am
yeah I don't remember exact phraseology
which he had but you say I am what I am
it is my faith not your faith it's my
name it's not your name I'm gonna be
what I am yes so that is the attitude
which America you know our neighbors are
good people they have sense of fair
hearing when Muhammad Ali took a stand
initially people were saying what is
this and all that people turn around
yeah people started loving him why
because of the character of truthfulness
that's the character of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him yeah you know he used
to pass our pamphlets with his write his
name on him Hamid did you know that I
will tell you it's the story if you like
I'll tell you the story you stood there
used to be an American Muslim Nichkhun
is abdullah he was an african-american
Muslim he was a major in Saudi Arabia he
became a Muslim he became president of
Muslim community center right here in
Chicago very talented person a business
executive so he wrote a brochure calles
Jesus really God so MCC refused to
publish it because they thought it's too
hard
so we both published it and we both will
stand on the south side 95th Street on
Dendera in this station we used to
distribute no no no me and build an eco
news up the lock so somebody told
Muhammad Ali that we distribute this
brush or so he came up with the two
suitcases to mcc ci' give me brochure so
the giving me all sort of Islam with
five pillars of my mom and yeah is five
pillars of Islam and all that he said no
no no I don't need that I need that one
and he showed them these Jesus really
got Muhammad Ali used to have his
personal book he showed me and in that
personal book he has the from Bible and
Quran is Jesus not real God so when he
could talk he used to argue with people
on these streets and everywhere about
that that was his type when he couldn't
talk there was were the days when he
found the brochures then he showed me
all hole hole crawling bag in a travel
bag he will have full of those brochures
so whenever people see him they will I
stop
they will I stop him I say autograph he
said no I'm not gonna write on that your
paper
he will take out the Davao brochure his
Jesus really God sign them and give it
to them he used to tell me he signs 500
brochures in one hour
I was photos with those things they gave
me a lot of those brochures
yeah the trip oi doctor merely right
that's where we connected him with dr.
Ramel Allah may Allah be pleased with
parameter this is look what's the excuse
if Muhammad Ali was doing it most
celebrities they'll run hide on a rock
that maybe China okay that Muhammad Ali
Muhammad Ali even if you go honest even
if you go on his museum brother I hope
you will take your camera and visit the
museum and tell him/her or tell the
Muslim world about it and tell Americans
about it in the museum of course just
like his life Islam and name and all
that is all over the museum but then
there is a large room which has no
Muhammad Ali just about Islam he even
his museum was focus on Dawa yeah now
what do you think after you know us a
very short pause of the horrific
horrific images you know that are always
associated you know these innuendoes you
say you know radical Islam jihadis the
ISIS these people have nothing to do
with Islam they're actually killing more
Muslims many people don't know that
we've done many shows on this and then
there was a slight pause not even 36
hours later you have this horrific
tragedy to handle set order in Orlando
yeah how much do you think would you say
is a lot of this stuff I mean I just
can't you know just for conversation is
cooked up I mean it just you know
obviously you know Islam has nothing to
do with this you have all these other
events that happen you mentioned almost
300
shootings that happen in 2015 their
religion is not mentioned you know they
always look for mentally disturbed what
happened in her childhood soon as
someone it's known the guy was in a
nightclub he was he was a homosexual he
was doing every beating his wife doing
everything opposite to Islam if he was
following Islam he wouldn't be in his
wrong place wrong time he wouldn't be
doing any of these radical things he'd
be a peaceful person making peace doing
what Muhammad Ali was doing for your
thoughts on well I cannot speak to
things which I don't know but you just
described the whole thing which even
media is telling us his guy was messed
up guys a huge type of personality
problem and his former wife things might
have pulled bipolar is he and current
wife poor girl has lower IQ has
difficulty learning so I don't know the
whole story there but one thing which is
clearly a person who was in that mosque
where he once in a while visited he says
he called FBI and telling them that this
person is has some strange ideas and
whatnot and if this article was printed
in Washington Post and Washington Post
verified with FBI and FBI said yes he
did tell us well what did you do about
it yeah I mean that seems like it yeah
so you you do have these tragic
incidents that happening but how much I
mean there was a I mean I just saw some
news I mean it's like taking the KKK for
instance I make this example and
constantly showing the KKK the
mainstream media people gonna end up
joining KKK people gonna they're gonna
rally support and then people are gonna
start thinking that that's mainstream
Christianity it's like these subliminal
messages are being sent as constantly
24/7 Isis staged like weeding out we got
other things you know to worry about
this fringe element you're just giving
them the platform to promote themselves
and their idea of whether there'll be no
Isis or nothing if we haven't for
nothing invaded Iraq there was no such
thing now we have five Muslim countries
completely destroyed invasion of nine
countries
drawn attacks on the other one according
to physicians for Social Responsibility
which is a Nobel Peace winning
organization in Washington DC only in
three countries Iraq Afghanistan and
Pakistan
they say 1.3 million muslims have been
killed because of the war war terrorism
and hate Islamophobia is a connected
phenomena you cannot stop it
one thing unless you stop the other
thing so it is important for Muslims and
our neighbors to stand up against what
the whole Isis phenomena didn't exist it
came because a whole country was
devastated then another country was
devastated then another country so
people some people go nuts
some people go crazy I mean in Chicago
40 people were shocked on the same
weekend fifty people died in Orlando why
you're not crying about what happened in
Chicago that just happened exactly the
same weekend brothers seven people died
at rest of the people were injured so so
I think we need to be very firm all
assault weapons need to be banned our
media need to be balanced in coverage
but Muslim are this to America to
isolate Islamophobe who are increasing
fear hate and anger in America our
neighbors are good people
Islamophobes using media skillfully are
confusing our neighbors those are the
real radicals right there they are the
mother of radicals the brother they have
the more common we will take a break now
they have more in common with these
extremist oh there they are the same
people the same yeah we're gonna take a
break and be right back with more here
daddy show don't go anywhere
subscribe to the D show follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
welcome back to the D so now you are on
The O'Reilly show and it was interesting
he was trying to always try to I mean
it's one thing coming on a program and
you're working to a good cause you know
for a common good seems like these
people always trying to trip you up
always trying to and then you got to a
point where he's talked about you know
someone to get you had
is wonderful this convention were stand
with Provost and with the profit yeah
against hate in love and peace
so did he end up showing up because you
invited him I invited him they brought
the truck but where they were supposed
to be in the press conference meeting
the gas I texted them several times they
didn't show up they wanted to go inside
our program and program was going on and
stick mic to people I say I will not
allow you to play games inside our
program there was one thing he said
something to you about unindicted
co-conspirator you say that's a good
thing being on a day wait a minute below
Bill O'Reilly yeah you should be happy
that he's unindicted you are running
toward if he's going to kill me indicted
being unindicted is something good not
bad why is it is a good thing why
because you are not indicted if there
was something you'll be indicted justice
never be mom you have I mean Bill
O'Reilly is an indicted I am unindicted
are you indicted brother
no okay so you're only dying so we got a
good company going here so whole America
is unindicted it is good thing for
America so they were using being
unindicted against mom sera jihad as
though it is some type of a curse or
something so so I think that was fine
and then he started what do you think
about this term this cliche now that's
all out there they keep throwing out
radical Islam yeah so I thought he was
radical because me you the fact of the
matter is that when they invited me on
the show I was sick that day actually as
soon as I was done with the show I
started putting mother I mean second
rack I throw up I couldn't finish my
salaat so I didn't want to go but sound
vision team voted that I must go there
so Allah helped me out and but reason
people wanted me not to go is people
thought is a radical activist he's not a
normal me
yeah but so I ended up telling him when
he used the term radical because the you
know the people coined the term they
stick it to people but Condoleezza Rice
secretary of state at the time of
President Bush she is the first one who
stopped using this radical Islam and
fascism Islam and Islamic terrorism
she's the one who stopped I went and I
personally thanked her on this and
President Obama continued not attaching
these things and now this Trump want to
use the same terminology why Cal
criminal a criminal a man in Chicago
forty people were shot who are the
shooter did he we call them a Christian
shooter killing other Christian
Christian fighting each other on the
street of Chicago we don't so-called
criminal a criminal a terrorist a
terrorist but attaching the beautiful
name of Islam to these things is not
acceptable and that's what I thought
bill reilly i hope he will remember that
lesson but if he invites me again i'm
willing to go and talk to him great so
there's no such thing if you're tuning
in you're our guest here you turn it for
the first time and you've heard this
term radical islam it's clear to say
it's easy it's it's emphatically we said
there's no such thing as a radical islam
you could be a radical individual but
islam is a beautiful way of life that's
from the crater its guidance for all of
mankind Jesus lived it Moses lived at
Abraham and the last the final measure
is that peace acquired by submission to
the world of the crater it cannot be
radical how could you how could you be a
radical submitter and peace to God and
brother Eddie and brother Mujahid are
trying to live that also on the
beautiful path of the prophets connect
with neighbors smile and tell them this
is what we believe in and respect other
people's faith and we all go back to
Almighty God and he will decide who was
right who was wrong but but but I think
what is important brother Eddie is that
you keep doing the good work which you
are doing I think the Dean show which is
watch on different satellite television
and all that it needs support of the
community Muslim need to realize that
you know you teach one person one-on-one
you're teaching
1% when you're teaching on television
you're teaching hundreds and thousands
of people if not Muslim need to master
the art and technology of communication
we need to be stronger and that's the
way America wants after 9/11 a lady
called me she picked up sound vision
brochure in some must said and she
called me and he said would you I'm not
a Muslim would you mind talking to me I
said of course by all means he said you
know a would channel should I look for
Islam I want to learn about Islam so
which channel I go to I remain silent
and say we don't have a channel you know
what did she say she remained silence
and then how do you know how do you
think Islam America will know about
Islam
how about America will know if you're
not on TV
yeah so thank you for being on TV and
let's do more of the same and I ask the
audience right here looking at you my
brothers and sisters if you feel you're
hurt if you feel you're being wrong if
you think Zuma is being done by Muslims
or people of other faiths you need to
speak stand up you need to speak up but
one of the things which you can do
people who are standing up people who
are speaking up with the television
program and radio and whatnot support
them that's our message need to be go
out just remember prophet salaallah
alayhi Salam use each and every means of
communication to connect whatever was
available at the time going to the
market going to the Kaaba going for Hajj
inviting pilferer party hey if Prophet
SAW Allah Allah's Salam is alive today
don't you think he will be on TV how you
can convey how you can talk to billions
of people unless you're on TV so
supporting TV and speak up and keep
smiling thank you so much Thank You
Sheikh for being with us on a dish thank
you people if they want to get a hold of
you you're the president of sound vision
yes they can go on sound vision calm or
radio Islam calm or just come knock on
the door in downtown Chicago and they
find me there I said thank you so much
for being thank you
it's LaMotta click there you have it
this week's episode of the Dene show you
got to learn 200 million dollars is
spent on bashing Islam and is it
succeeding you be the judge there's a
lot of false information but the person
who is sincere and really wants to know
the purpose of life why they've been
created they asked earnestly o my Maker
the one who made me guide me guide me to
what my purpose is in this life I know
I'm gonna have to die and at the end I'm
gonna leave all that money and the
wealth behind and I'm gonna spend my
life chasing my tail going around in
circles from Monday to Friday just
working like a dog sweating laboring
hard to go to the pub and a nightclub on
the weekend and have a hangover the next
day and then what Monday comes you know
the highest level of suicide is on what
day Monday and maybe you don't commit
suicide maybe you're not on Prozac but
you're close to it why because there's a
void in the heart and you're just
filling it with all of this hate
rhetoric Fox News can you imagine if you
spent that time more wisely more
appropriately seeking to really know
what the purpose of life is what does
that feel when you spend your time
watching Bill O'Reilly Fox News and all
of the other sensationalism that's built
up around this fake boogeyman that's
been created haven't you give up your
rights because you're scared you
shouldn't fear no one but the Creator
when you're upon truth when you're doing
good when you're like Muhammad Ali was
the American hero who was out there
propagating the truth he was on a firm
ground you should be someone who takes
that example and also applies it and I'm
gonna end with this quote here from the
verbatim Word of God the Quran where
Allah the Almighty God is saying evil is
not equal to what's wholesome even
though evil is so widespread that it
seems normal
good to you be mindful of God all you
people of understanding so you may
prosper that's right be mindful of God
being mindful of your purpose in life
make this world a better place
have peace of your creator peace within
yourself and go ahead and enjoy the
blessings that the Creator has given you
and one of the best and best blessings
is to know your purpose to share your
purpose to live your purpose thank you
for tuning into the D show every week we
got a new exciting show for you until
next time peace be with you
assalamualaikum millions are spent to
get people away from Islam we're asking
you to contribute very little to help
share and bring people to this beautiful
way of life Islam now what are you gonna
do with that how much are you gonna put
in how much are you going to contribute
to help us grow this channel to continue
the work it's something that's incumbent
on all of us we've taken up the call
we're doing our small part to me a lost
want Allah I accept it from us and from
you as you contribute there's a link
below and we'll see you next time keep
us in your dua and subscribe if you
haven't already to get this newest show
delivered to you every Friday we release
it helps support the Dawa helps support
our spreading the message of peace and
purpose to the world until next time
we'll see you the Salaam alaikum peace
be with you